so first of all I loved the book
um thank you so cute
um it's so fun my wife and I are like
super excited to uh read the book to our
niece
um and your whole Artistry is very
centered around kindness and this so
this seems like a very organic
progression for you but what inspired
you to write a children's book
well they asked me
um no I was um so I had I had written uh
and co-written a children's EP album in
2019 called Dragon's magic and
um
already the space uh you know of
traveling and being a drag artist
during the the Trump era of during his
presidency was already a [ __ ] it had
some red flags there were some
challenges and
um then I released that kids album and a
lot of different things happened and uh
for in and personally you know um that
were challenging for me to to deal with
and understand and
um I think it just only reiterated the
importance of the work that I wanted to
do which was to be in a family space uh
first for a lot of my career you know
um align myself with Brands like doing
it with Nickelodeon and do work that
would be far-reaching for
queer families whether they be queer
parents or parents of queer children
um
and then a book agent had heard the
children's album and had come to me and
you know during this kind of like really
uproarious little time period of my own
life and said hey you know this is
really great opportunity for you to
write a children's book we want to do
something initially it was going to be
something like based off of one of the
songs you know one of the ideas was like
doing the drag alphabet or doing uh a a
like a lyrical book version of dragon's
magic and I said no actually I really
want to create my own story I want to
create like a fresh new
uh new piece which which felt
um more
um
I think organic for me you know like
it's one thing to take lyrics to a thing
and put it to a picture book
um but I had I felt like I had done that
already with the music video and with
kind of like I was like this feels done
you know like and so I wanted to create
something new and so you kind of kind
was born and it was
um really a it was like a love letter to
I think drag queens who are doing story
times and
um queer parents who are reading aloud
to their kids who had fought so hard for
be it their own biological children or
adopted kids uh
um specifically those queer parents in
my own life who uh were friends of mine
who had you know fight we finally got
marriage equality and
um in 2015 and we and they were building
their own families here five years later
and
um I think that that's where it really
all started from and I have to be honest
with you also I would never have known
three years later how important it would
have been you know like
um how pressing it was to have a drag
queen like myself
write a kid's book
um and have it be uh coming out during
this time period where there's so much
going on that directly affects lgbtq
Value Plus people drag artists whether
it be the don't say gay bill or Idaho
trying to put a bill into their legisl
into their legislature regarding drag
performances and outline drag
performances or Texas or pick a state
right um so I didn't know how how
pressing this would be and I think
there's a reason why it's happening the
way it is so I'm grateful to be a voice
of that so you mentioned your the
children's album and so both in both the
album and the book you address things
that are fundamental or fundamentally
um associated with drag and queer
culture but in a way it makes those
things very accessible to Children which
I think is absolutely potential
um they found my own queer childhood
would have benefited from someone like
who does what you do
um mine too honestly yeah uh how what
did you how did you decide to
um
sort of just lean into creating media
that is both inherently clear and
specifically for kids
yeah
that's a really great question because
uh I you know when I I had expressed I
had I had expressed my desire to do this
um
prior so we filmed drag race right I
mean like what
well let me take a step back my because
like it's all it's all kind of built on
itself
um I was I've been doing drag for 22
years and creating creating content
writing live shows building Production
shows for 18 years prior to my ever
being on drag race and so I had done a
nightclub act which is like a very adult
oriented 18 and over at that's you know
specific for a nightclub I have done uh
I've done acts that were uh story times
or drag brunches where families would be
present and um I just saw this as a
natural evolution of my own drag career
right like
um and so when I went on drag race I I
you know I I am a queen of assert I am I
am a I am a certain type of Queen right
so like I'm a camp queen I'm a comedy
queen I am I you know I'm a writer I'm a
I'm a director I'm a producer I kind of
I kind of do it I'm an actor I kind of
you know like in every man of dragon in
a sense where
um I Really Wanna I really have a very
strong point of view and
um and I happen to be rooted in I think
a lot of
uh not to something not to betrayed but
I'm rooted I think in kindness and
rooted in
um like uh a big I'm just a big kid I'm
a big big old kid and I'm six foot four
44 year old body
I'm like you know and so I was trying to
connect to that and that's what drew me
to wanting to be in these spaces was
that these those were the things that
inspired me when I was a kid it was the
Muppets it was Disney it was
um uh animated it was Looney Tunes and
Warner Brothers cartoons I mean it was
like all of these things you know like
that had like really inspired me as a
kid to pull voices and make faces and
um be goofy and silly and then I lost a
lot of that even in my own self and I
was coming out I was I would became very
ashamed of who I was and
um I thought any one of those things
made me a marker for being queer and gay
and that scared me you know and so I
really I tampered everything down I tone
myself down and um
I just I the only you said it I I I
would have really benefited from
something like this as a kid would have
saved me a lot of heartache and pain to
know that someone out there to seem to
see someone queer out there being
successful and being uh healthy and
being
um their authentic selves and not facing
um
repercussions for who they are and so
that's why I think I I'm here on this
space that's why I believe in it fully
and intrinsically and through and
through and I know the importance of it
and the value of it and
um I also know that I'm like I I know
that I am the person to do it you know
like I'm one of the I'm I'm one of many
people to do this
um and exist in this world and tell
these stories that are enveloped in love
and in kindness and acceptance and
diversity and and preventing space and
agency that are very very vital
especially now when we're when we see it
all be
picked apart and targeted and ripped
away and
um yeah I mean that's why that's a long
answer and it's really complicated but
no it's a very good but you know what I
mean like that's why I mean like I want
to be I want to be a Beacon of Hope I
want to be a Bastion for change I want
to make sure that that your kids I don't
have kids but I want to make sure your
kids are my friends kids and my friends
who are who are in these relationships
all are able to sustain and go on and
live the life that they've always
dreamed of and we've had our hands on it
right we've touched it you know and now
it's being pulled away at us and it
requires all of us as uh specifically
queer people to really put a flag in the
ground and put a stake in the ground and
say these are things that we we that we
value and that we swear by and we live
by and these are tenets of who we are as
a community and as a people and we will
defend and protect them and like so
that's and so like I'm choosing to say
that I think the family unit matters in
a queer family and I'm and I'm choosing
to say that in turn queer parents and
parents of queer children have the right
to choose the kind of content that they
want to expose their children to and in
turn I'm asking Brands like Disney and
Nickelodeon to see this and validate
this and say yes you two have queer
subscribers and queer your parents who
are who are who are consuming your
product they too want this contact and
they too want access to this and they
too deserve to have their stories told
and so that's where this all is and all
of it's like circling around each other
and kind of building off of one another
to I think to in this to tell these
stories yes absolutely and I'm sorry for
that no that's
um
things that really
me is that you offer advice for both the
bullied and the bullies themselves which
I don't feel like I see a lot of
children's books talk to the bully
um so how did you decide to sort of
offer that Grace to kids who may be
bullying for any reason
uh because
I think that we all intrinsically
are uh we all at our core deserve love
we all deserve respect we all deserve an
act of kindness and the greatest act and
the greatest act of kindness that you
can give to someone who is who is being
mean to you is to say I see I see
and
um and I think that that was a bit that
is a very obviously it's a book but it's
a it is a very designed choice
um and it's a larger it's a it's a much
larger louder uh representation of I
think life for adults you know like we
are in this world now that requires us I
think to We Can't yell into The Ether
you know we have to be willing to
especially now we've got to figure out
how we're going to talk to each other
because at the end of the day that I
mean we are going to have to deal with
one another
um and um and and I think allowing uh
advice for a bully
um in these in these contexts also shows
that everyone can you can make a defined
choice
to be the person who is who is uh the
bully or you can make a Divine choice to
be the person who goes out into the
world and gives kindness and gives the
gift to Graham and gives the these
wonderful these Wonder puzzle was bastic
you know gestures that provide hope and
enjoy for others and that bully too
should have the opportunity to see
themselves in the story and say I can
also do this and I can let go of this
and become something better so the art
in this book is just absolutely stunning
by Hayden Williams
um how involved were you in
um sort of crafting the vision of the
book and just there's people of all
kinds in in the book which is essential
and yeah yeah it's again when people
read the book when whether it's whether
it's a a Storyteller reading it aloud
for an audience or if the reader
themselves are reading it privately I
did write the book to be read aloud it
is a book that's meant to be shared and
spoken loudly right what these
incredible
um one of my favorite aspects is that we
created this language like our own words
for the book which was inspired by the
Sherman Brothers uh who wrote Mary
Poppins
um
uh but I wanted to create I wanted to
create a a story that allowed people to
I think
experience it in real time
um and so in that
um
these I think that's you know so much
value in
um having the story
be shared in such a way
um I completely completely forgot the
question
good um
wait what did what was the question
I'm sorry what did you have oh my God I
haven't done that ever sorry all good
it's just about like how you felt about
making sure that the visuals of the book
[Laughter]
I was like okay Andrew you just gotta
ask you just gotta ask one of the
questions because you forget
um yeah so I worked in
Hayden sorry okay
um Hayden is brilliant and I really do
feel like he kind of created his own his
own style of illustration for the book
if you look at the pictures they're
really layered and there's a lot of
texture like even if you look at the cut
like cover there's all these like in
that rainbow pattern there's stars and
there's magic and like everything is
just feels
the art and the illustration feels fresh
and it feels nostalgic at the same time
like it feels very familiar
um and so we when we were talking about
it I remember saying to him like he's
like oh who are some of your
Inspirations like so I can have an idea
of like capturing the essence of Nina
like what are some of those things that
you really have looked towards I've
created your own tapestry of Nina West
and I was like well if we're going to
talk about art you know Mary Blair who
is a very famous Disney artist who who
did like
uh the design for It's A Small World did
the design the storyboards for Alice in
Wonderland and Peter Pan just this very
Whimsical beautiful
um kind of like a bit like
fairy tale ask but very
the colors were just so vivid and then
Brittany Lee who's another Disney artist
who uh had done who's done a lot of like
um art for projects like Frozen
um where the use of color and shape
helped tell the story and if you really
the shape of this book Hayden really
captured that we wanted to work in I
remember just having simple
conversations about shakes and how a
young eye would view the book so we
wanted to go we really wanted to go with
round and soft and uh curves that
provided a lot of I think wonder and an
infinite hope of potential and kindness
right and what circles represent and so
like a lot of how you see the artwork
it's very it's very rounded it's not
angular
um but the backdrops provide angles
um so it started there and then it
became
color palette and then it became
um then he started to provide the
layouts and
we would make small adjustments
uh and
of the like but
it was like once we got to that point
Hayden was really very much he knew we
were friends so prior to this
collaboration so he knew who I was as a
person he knew who he knew how I had
informed decisions with Nina so it
seemed really logical
in his uh adaptation of that for the
storytelling of the book and I can't say
enough I mean I'm really lucky that I
get to be his first book because I think
this is just the beginning for him and I
think that we're gonna get to see his
art
on a lot of other projects and I think
that's really exciting for Haiti and for
his family because this is like
I think this is just the beginning
absolutely
um speaking of the art I'm pretty sure I
spotted Dolly Parton in there
um pretty sure she's right there yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure you also got an
endorsement from the queen herself um
how do you feel about having that stamp
of approval
um I I mean like in a book about
kindness
and about giving kindness and about
discovering kindness I don't think
there's a better
a better example of how to live a life
based on kindness enjoy them with Dolly
Parton and so
I mean it's over it's it's a pinch me
moment it's of the worldly I mean it's
it's uh
it's I don't what is this life and what
is this reality I don't know but I do
know that I'm very grateful that she has
been
so
um lovingly attentive to me into my
career and very invested in the kindness
of and the style of kindness that I give
through my art of drag you know I think
it's very
um
it says a lot right Dolly does she says
a lot without saying anything
um
you know like and I think that's the
value of her she's traditionally and
very uh
apolitical she doesn't really get
involved in a lot of political
conversation
um but I think we know where she stands
on
um supporting I think queer voices and
queer artists and our community and how
we too can be messengers of kindness and
I think that's really important because
she has such a wide fan base
of people who come from all walks of
light uh all over the world and
she's she's she has told people through
this action that she values this and
that's really powerful so besides Dolly
and yourself uh are there any other
illustrations that you and Hayden snuck
in there of people yes no people that
you that we might know
yeah there's a bunch of there's a bunch
of Easter eggs in the book
um so uh there's a there are if you look
and so little so there's a ton of Easter
eggs when you open up the book the book
opens the exact same way that hairspray
open so
um we see when we open the very first
page of action we see little Nina in her
bed as like it's almost like the camera
we're looking down on her the minds of
the the audience viewers eyes looking
down at Nina it's exactly the same way
Hairspray the music that starts which is
which is literally a tribute to Jack
O'Brien the director of hairspray which
is exactly celebrating that
um if you look at the second page I'm
just gonna go through a couple of them
page
um you can see RuPaul as opposed to a
RuPaul on the wall uh which I wanted to
celebrate again these are celebrating
I'm celebrating people who have allowed
me to have these opportunities right so
uh little Nina celebrates your palm uh
if you go to the next layout I'm gonna
get I get
um
when little Nina goes into her closet to
find her outfit for the day
um if you look at the outfits they're
all on different incarnations and
representations of my drag career so
you'll see uh the outfit that I wear is
in the term lad right here uh went from
Welcome to the 60s you'll see my story
time outfit right here which is uh I did
for
um all over the pandemic and it's the
outfit from the drag off of that music
video which I used for all of my story
time this is my entrance book for
Rupaul's Drag Race
um season 11 was my yellow outfit and
then these this here this rainbow outfit
is also a salute to
um my Nickelodeon collaboration with
Blue's Clues
um because that's how I was animated in
this outfit and this is the dude and
this is a Disney salute here with uh
with the hat that coincides uh for uh
Mickey Mouse and Walt Disney
um and then there are of course a couple
other hidden uh Easter eggs that I don't
want to give away because I want the
readers to find them but I will say on
this page here
um well I mean this obvious one Nicole
buyer is right here Nicole buyer's a
friend of mine
and I wanted to celebrate uh her and
comedy and how important it is that we
we celebrate and we can laugh with one
another I think it's a really big thing
um
uh there's a there's John Waters is in
the book right here walking outside
another hairspray hearty heart
celebration with John Waters is right
here on the Block
um and she said dollies in the book and
then my best friend Patricia who I've
been friends with for 22 years my best
best friend she's in the book uh walking
my dogs
um right here these two are my dogs uh
Edgar and Felicity uh my parents are in
the book
um my sisters have representations in
the book
um dollies in the book Hayden has a few
Easter eggs with his family in the book
uh there's a couple
um a more celebrity spottings and even
like just Nina West is um within the
book that uh a true Nina West band will
find and I think you'd be like fine joy
and like oh my gosh that's so cool so
yeah it's um
I couldn't have imagined this ever
happening I'm gonna be honest with you
um
and it's happening in such a I I
couldn't couldn't have understood the
time period of it and when it's
happening and just in really grateful
but it's happening to me at all
I love that you guys were able to
include all of those little Easter eggs
just by looking around at your own life
and and the book is then in turn very
representative of all kinds of people
because all kinds of people are involved
in your life
um so you have a bit in the book about
making up words what is your favorite
word that you've made up
I love wasbastic I love the word was
[ __ ]
um and they'll just so I have created
these characters called Wuzzles and
they're uh they are in another iteration
of another book that I've written uh
that may or may not ever see the light
of day uh but when I was working on this
manuscript with my editor I had this
everyone's like I love this idea of
these things that give us this feeling
and
um so was fast it was and is kind of
this uh representation throughout the
Book of when you give kindness you feel
less [ __ ] and in turn the act of
kindness begets all these little stars
all around you that hey
perfectly and beautifully casters and so
these little stars are representations
of that was [ __ ] feeling that kind of
so what's [ __ ] to me is the best my
favorite word but like this superb Lewis
and uh and um giftogram I give you know
like and I wrote I I wrote a song to co
to be released with this book called The
you kind of kind that has this lyric
video that also comes out next Tuesday
and it's um and there are also other
like words in that you know snippery
snappery sleuth you know being something
that's not afraid to go out into the
world and like discover and
um again it's an homage to things that I
when I was a kid I mean you couldn't
have told me supercalifragilistic
Expialidocious what's the best word in
the world and so it was like
I you know and I was and you know as you
grow and like you you you know you learn
things and I learned that you know like
the Sherman Brothers just delighted in
creating
words for kids and families to get
tongue-tied on and to celebrate and find
the joy and excitement and there was a
kinetic energy in that that I really
wanted to create as well and
was [ __ ] I think it's like a really
great first extension of I think World
building for this which I love so you
recently got to play drag Legend Divine
in the biopic weird which comes out next
month in just a couple weeks uh can you
talk a bit about that experience and
what was like what you did to prepare
and what it was like to embody such a
touchstone of queer culture and carry
that Legacy as a touchdown of queer
culture yourself
yeah I mean it's um it's really cool
because I feel like you know a lot of
these roads are intersecting and all
these Fabrics are like being woven to
create like this this kind of a career
that I'm having right now and I'm
experiencing because you know I'm doing
Hairspray the musical which the original
role of Edna term lab was created by
Divine in the John Waters film in 1988
uh who and John Waters and divine of
these massive you know queer icons and
then the role of Edna was Harvey
firesteins which he won a Tony Award for
on Broadway math Harvey piracy massive
queer voice you know icon uh who wrote
torch song Trilogy in La Casa Foe and
um the book to kingkeepers I mean the
man is prolific and it's the
storytelling for our community and so
then to go to you know to be on the road
on tour I forget where I was I might
have been in Detroit or Chicago when I
got the call and said hey we have this
offer for you to go to uh Los Angeles
for a day and shoot um The Weird Al
Yankovic movie with Daniel Radcliffe and
you're going to be divine and it was
um
like a another like what the hell like
Pinch Me Moment Like This is not real to
um
I think perfectly fitting right Divine
is someone who
uh led a life
very
um seemingly very
um Fearless Fierce and brave and
um was just a true original and weirdo
Yankovic is a true original you know
like there's no one like Al and Daniel
Radcliffe is a true original there's no
one like it
and you know my book new kind of kind
I'm asking people to celebrate their
true originality they're you and it just
you know
to go do that project was like I mean
absolutely a highlight of my career I
couldn't
I couldn't have
dreamed of anything more fantastic or
fabulous I think uh Eric who's the
director of uh weird is brilliant Al
Yankovic is one of the nicest people
I've ever encountered in the industry if
not in my life
um who was absolutely so caring and so
committed to
his crew and his team and his actors
coming together to share this wonderful
story in a such a fantastically fabulous
way and you know my preparation really
was uh getting a script and like getting
getting on a plane and sneaking away to
Los Angeles for a couple days to go do
this high profile top secret project and
then coming back to the show missing
only one show literally landing at five
o'clock in Madison Wisconsin for the
Wednesday night show at 7 30 going
straight to the theater and getting
ready to do a show Without Really people
knowing that I'd been gone and
um
I think all of that just led to a really
exciting exciting time in my life that
is now coming out to the world and you
know and it comes out like
simultaneously like the week after my
book is released and
um it all just feels
purely serendipitous and fantastic and
wonderful and I think if there's
anything we can learn from the life of
Weird Al it's that you know beat to Your
Own Drum and be you yeah wonderful and
weird and be weird there's no I think
there's something fabulous about being
weird
absolutely
um so lastly you're set to host the drag
queen Christmas tour
um starting yeah even
um what can you tell people about that
get the fans excited yeah drag queen
Christmas I'm I'm returning this is my
third year as their host I get to host
in 2019 that hosted the virtual event
with Trinity uh in 2020 and then uh I'm
back again this year for the tour on
2022 and uh you know this is like such a
fun fantastic celebration of the holiday
season with your favorite drag artists I
mean we have artists from uh we've got
Jimbo from Canada's Dragon race Todrick
Hall Trinity the talk
um
let's start over
but we have a bunch of dragons from
Todrick Hall Trinity the talk
um Brooklyn Heights Jimbo from Kansas
drag race
um the the Manila Luzon the lift is so
long and so vast and it's every city
lineup is different
um but we're touring all over the
country I think it's like
36 cities I'm doing 29 of those
um and I can't wait to celebrate the
holiday season with everybody excellent
that's amazing
um I hope that maybe we can catch you on
tour
um that'd be lovely please come
thank you so much for taking the time to
chat with me uh you're one of our
favorite Queens here in my very queer
household
um
so I couldn't be more honored to speak
with you and I hope you have a
superbuous day
thank you I hope you have a waspastic
weekend thank you so much for taking me
thank you thank you